[Música]
en Primera Plana
Carlos herranz
[Música]
Bienvenidos en Primera Plana de radio
Francia internacional y de france24
estrenamos hoy la cuarta temporada del
programa con el mismo espíritu de
siempre cada semana analizar un tema
monográfico con nuestros invitados desde
varias perspectivas un tema que tiene
repercusión global y del que intentamos
situar todas las claves esta semana
ponemos el foco en la variante Delta y
cómo ha reconfigurado la situación de la
pandemia en el mundo nos acompañan ya en
este estudio Joan cortinas Muñoz
sociólogo del instituto de ciencias
políticas de París experto en políticas
públicas bienvenido Gracias Carlos Iván
Sánchez periodista en radio Francia
Internacional de la rúbrica salud y
ciencia bienvenida ivon y mi compañera
Cristian capuchino periodista de la
reacción brasileña de recibí bienvenida
la variante Delta hoy en plana
más de 135 países en todo el mundo ya
han detectado la presencia de la
variante delta del virus que causa la
covid-19 Y se cree que en los próximos
meses se convertirá en la variante
dominante a nivel mundial la
preocupación por Delta no ha hecho más
que incrementar las ya grandes
diferencias de acopio de vacunas entre
países ricos y países pobres pese a los
llamados de la Organización Mundial de
la Salud para la solidaridad como
elemento fundamental para erradicar la
pandemia Lo cierto es que mientras
muchos ricos ya proyectan sus campañas
para la tercera dosis de la vacuna
algunas naciones por ejemplo en África
no cuentan ni con el 1% de su población
vacunada analizamos toda esta situación
global con nuestros invitados pero antes
repasemos algunas portadas que ilustran
este tema aquí en Francia el diario
Lemon se pregunta si podemos lograr la
ansiedad de inmunidad colectiva en este
contexto de Delta que hace aumentar el
porcentaje necesario de población para
alcanzarla en el morgen post alerta
sobre el inicio del curso escolar y la
duda de vacunar a los alumnos Y a partir
de qué edad y todo ello mientras en
varios países occidentales continúan las
protestas de los anti vacunas así lo
refleja esta otra portada de The journal
en Reino Unido tras los últimos
enfrentamientos de vacunas y fuerzas del
orden bueno la variante Delta y las
grandes diferencias en acopio de vacunas
configuran ahora mismo el escenario
mundial en la lucha contra la pandemia
Joan la falta de solidaridad o de visión
global de la pandemia no sé si es ahora
podríamos decir que es el mayor riesgo
que tenemos sobre la mesa totalmente más
que falta eso era yo diría de multi
lateralidad no es decir esta pandemia ha
puesto de nuevo en evidencia que los
mecanismos la OMS la Organización
Mundial de salud que esto han encargados
de poder coordinar las diferentes
naciones los diferentes países no son
efectivas no son eficaces y no tienen un
peso real sino que la OMS se limita a
hacer llamados los llamados son no son
positivos pero evidentemente no hay
estructuras que permitan generar esta
coordinación tan necesaria para que nos
salgamos de este mal sueño o esta vez
pesadilla que consiste en vivir en
variante después de variante y hace dos
años que estamos así no Entonces
evidentemente nos está visibilizando
esta necesidad de coordinación y de
estructuras que permitan coordinar la
salud a nivel mundial y de momento no
las tenemos esta expansión de la
variante Delta hace que volvamos no
volvamos a ver la luz al final del túnel
es ansiada luz que intentamos ver del
final de la crisis sanitaria entre otras
cosas porque se va de ese Espejismo de
la inmunidad de grupo No ahora
necesitaríamos más población todavía
vacunada ivón bueno bueno en enero 2021
estábamos aquí y el tema fue la vacuna
es que es la buena noticia la esperanza
la esperanza de la buena vacuna no y
ahora parece que ni con esas
Y ahora resulta que está esta variante
Delta y
Bueno yo creo que sí va a haber la luz
al final del túnel hay que hay que hay
que hacer positivos hay que tener
esperanza no pero bueno por el momento
las cosas están complicando un poco
quizás Bueno todavía no sabemos mucho no
quizás este seguir con esta lucha por
vacunarse y bueno tratar de ganarle la
carrera a esta cuarta o tercera ola
depende de en donde estemos situados
Pero qué factores explican que se haya
expandido tanto la variante Delta
Durante este verano porque las
mutaciones por sí solas son una
explicación pero también estará la
relajación en cuanto a las medidas
sociales No sí que en muchos países
quitáramos las mascarillas en las
fronteras se abrían y entonces que claro
que la transmisión sabemos que se da de
una persona a otra si estamos en
contacto con otras personas ella incluso
había que una variante que es más
contagiosa claro que eso lo vas a
expandir más rápido
acabamos con ese Espejismo de la
inmunidad colectiva Joan bueno eso
parece En todo caso con el Espejismo de
que si los países ricos tienen consiguen
inmunidad colectiva y no estamos lejos
Por cierto me acuerdo sí que hablábamos
en enero fue cuando decíamos Francia va
tan mal no sé qué Y al final estamos
todos más o menos allí evidentemente si
no se establecen mecanismos de
cooperación que permitan vacunar al
planeta entero la inmunidad colectiva
será un Espejismo una un sueño que no
vamos a alcanzar el verano boreal aquí
en Francia ha estado marcado por
manifestaciones antivacunas y anti
certificados sanitarios manifestaciones
que no tienen tanta importancia Quizá en
otros países europeos les ha sorprendido
el movimiento aquí en Francia
Bueno yo te podría decir que les ha
sorprendido un poco en México yo estoy
vengo de mi experiencia de estar de
haber pasado el verano en México de
vacaciones y allí También hay un
movimiento anti vacunas pero es un poco
diferente entonces el hecho de que de
que primero se hizo obligatoria la
vacuna a ciertos profesionales y luego
lo del certificado este sanitario como
que y y bueno Y también aunado eso las
las manifestaciones anti vacunas como
que eso realmente hizo un eco este los
mexicanos están muy al pendiente de lo
que estaba pasando en Francia pero por
ambas partes por la tanto por la vacuna
obligatoria como por el las
manifestaciones anti vacunas entonces
bueno se puede decir que por distintas
razones se se están dando estos estos
fenómenos Cristian a usted le ha
sorprendido la amplitud del movimiento
que hemos visto en Francia todos los
sábados manifestándose Durante este
verano boreal los antivacunas en la
calle es verdad que en los últimos en
las últimas fechas ha decrecido un poco
el creo que ya he esperado ya lo
esperaba en Francia porque de verdad que
hay mucho más manifestaciones aquí pero
esta semana subimos en Italia y en
Italia me sorprendido más en Italia no
sé si sabes pero tuvieron que meter la
policía en todas en todos los trenes
para por el por el tema del certificado
sanitario y hubo amenazas de muerte
contra de ministros contra presidentes
de religión entonces que está muy
violento en otros países también Incluso
en Alemania tuvieron problemas también
con los certificados de manifestaciones
más violentas que en Francia y yo esa
mirada un poco los datos de vacunación y
vi por ejemplo aquí en Francia estamos
como un 60% de la población con falta
completa pero en Suiza al lado tenemos
50 por ciento entonces no es solo una
cosa de Francia como decía yo voy
como experto en políticas de salud el
pase sanitario el es la herramienta
adecuada para combinar salud y economía
difícil pregunta
bueno Es una herramienta que como todo
el mundo sabe genera problemas a nivel
jurídico es decir ataca ciertas
libertades individuales entre las cuales
el consentimiento un tratamiento médico
que es una libertad fundamental y por
eso en ese sentido es problemática luego
evidentemente no es lo mismo hablar de
libertades y de eficacia puede ser un
método eficaz evidentemente desde que
anunció macrón que no se podría ir a
casi ningún sitio sin pase sanitario de
golpe subieron la gente que se fue a
vacunar Entonces en ese sentido sí que
podemos decir que ha sido eficaz y si
hubiera sido bien justificada de nuevo
de manera excepcional porque no lo que
pasa como siempre yo tengo la impresión
eh Y no quiero entrar en la crítica
fácil no se han explorado todas las
pistas antes de tomar la medida más
radical parece que uno haya pasado el 0
a 100 en dos minutos muchas veces no es
decir no se podían haber hecho cosas
intermedias antes de llegar a la medida
más complicada a nivel de libertad es
individuales
y retomo aquí el hilo de lo que decías
tú las manifestaciones a mí me han
sorprendido porque Claro si no si si no
me hubieran sorprendido quiere decir que
he visto venir el tema no pero lo
importante es qué razones hacen que la
gente se movilice y yo creo que en cada
país hay distintas razones no lo que nos
muestra es que el virus es político y de
nuevo genera un debate político y es
digerido por el sistema político aquí en
Francia me da la impresión los sábados
el mismo tipo de población me me
recuerdo un poco a las ardillas
amarillas no los chalecos amarillos de
qué está pasando macron tiene como una
manga ancha cuando se trata del mercado
las empresas pues no vamos a hacer
regulaciones muy estrictas tal cuando se
trata de los ciudadanos de ciertas
categorías hay como una manga menos más
estrechita y eso me parece que es lo que
se está revelando ciudades no están creo
tanto contra el pase sanitario que
contrasta doble rasero de política que
está haciendo desde el gobierno francés
en otros países seguramente son otras
razones que hay que estudiarlas y
explorarlas me parece que no sé si que
relativizarlo de las manifestaciones
porque sí su número ha ido descendiendo
en las últimas semanas y al mismo tiempo
sí que los sondeos muestran que hay una
mayoría de la población que sí que está
a favor de la medida
Bueno yo quisiera regresar un poco atrás
no sobre la variante Delta porque
preguntabas un poco porque hay tantos
contagios O sea si hay una diferencia es
decir la variante anterior este la Alfa
y quizás también la Beta la del Reino
Unido y la y la primera Exacto era había
un de una persona contagiada se podían
contagiar dos ese era la proporción el
radio y ahora es una persona contagiada
puede contagiar a seis o siete personas
o sea claro Entonces es normal que haya
esta este aumento exponencial de
contagios entonces Bueno eso es nada más
ser un pequeño paréntesis para recordar
que sí es más contagioso y bueno que que
es lo que está explicando este esta Pues
esta Nueva Ola que nadie se esperaba
estábamos viendo en India que estaba
sucediendo esto pero nadie un poco como
cuando estábamos viendo que estaba
sucediendo algo en China y las pocas
semanas estamos todos Ahora muchos
países por no decir casi la viviendo
esta esta tercera o cuarta ola Delta era
más bien sobre eso esta semana el
periódico Liberación hablaba de los
arrepentidos bajo un titular una
antivacunas que comentaba he sido
egoísta vacunarse es un acto de civismo
creen que esta transformación de los
anti vacunas se puede dar con argumentos
conocen casos parecidos es útil frente a
la irracionalidad intentar convencer con
argumentos se puede hacer o es una
batalla perdida contra un segmento de la
población yo no creo que hay batallas
perdidas cuando hablamos de humanos pero
tal vez como decía Juan tenemos que
conocer que cuáles son sus argumentos
pero porque tienen gente contra vacunas
que no tiene los mismos argumentos de
otros Entonces qué es Es que tiene miedo
Es que crees que la tecnología ha sido
muy rápida es que tal vez no tenemos con
las políticas públicas han sido
implementadas de una manera que tiene
que ir a un centro la vacunación no
tiene eso en la calle tiene que pasar
por un médico no puede entonces no hay
médico no puede vacunar hay otras cosas
que tal vez hizo la gente no ir hasta la
vacuna No necesariamente son
negacionistas no creen en la ciencia y
cosas y cosas así
Exactamente eso es decir hay mucha gente
hay las razones son muy variadas y
diversas efectivamente que estudiar qué
está pasando no también estoy de acuerdo
contigo No creo que los que manifiestan
sea la mayoría de población porque la
mayoría de población parece que está de
acuerdo pero los únicos que yo creo que
es más complicado cambiar es cuando el
tema de las vacunas y el pase sanitario
ha sido incorporado como a mi visión del
mundo y a mi posición política Claro en
este caso toda convicción todo argumento
racional está perdido vale Pero hay
mucha gente que no está en este en este
lado sino no sí que dice ostias que la
vacuna igual ha ido muy rápido no ha
habido estudios ahí sí que hay que poner
la máquina y comunicación social y
política desde el gobierno ahí para
intentar justamente que esa gente pues
vaya poco a poco pues aceptando y
aceptando digamos basándose en
argumentos racionales hacemos en este
punto una breve pausa y enseguida
continuamos hablando en Primera Plana de
la variante Delta y sobre todo a la
vuelta de las diferencias en el acceso a
las vacunas algo que puede complicar
mucho que acabemos con esta pandemia
hasta ahora
[Música]
y 4.com está disponible en 4 idiomas
artículos reportajes noticias
internacionales continuamente todas
nuestras emisiones para ver de nuevo y
el canal en directo 24 horas los siete
días intuitivo rápido y en cuatro
lenguas France 24.com
Todas las semanas tenemos una cita para
hablar es de mujeres en ellos hoy
hablamos de nuestra diversidad nuestros
logros y nuestras luchas constantes aquí
entrevistamos a las que generan el
cambio en el mundo y les contamos sus
historias
[Música]
ella soy en francés 24.com
seguimos en Primera Plana esta semana
hablando de La amenaza Delta sobre el
mundo que parece retrasar el final de la
crisis sanitaria lo hacemos con el
sociólogo Joan cortinas Muñoz experto en
políticas de salud y mis compañeras
Ivonne Sánchez de la rúbrica de ciencia
y salud de recí y Cristian capuchino de
la redacción brasileña discursos de
solidaridad pero fachada de fachada pero
compras anticipadas y acopio exclusivo
de vacunas en el fondo en esta realidad
se han movido los países ricos en los
últimos meses pese a los llamados
constantes de varias organizaciones
entre ellas la OMS para advertir que
solo el combate global puede acabar con
la pandemia la llegada de nuevas
variantes como Delta incluso podemos
decir a incrementado estas diferencias
no entre unos y otros en la copia de
vacunas Cristian sí que ha incrementado
y ahora lo riesgo que tenemos es que hay
hubo una una variante que pase por la
vacuna y ahora tenemos un riesgo con la
variante en mí la cosa es cuanto menos
gente inmunizada más variantes tendremos
Es que fíjense tengo aquí algunos datos
Canadá por ejemplo cuenta ahora mismo
con 11 dosis de vacuna por persona
Estados Unidos 5,5 lo más preocupante es
que ahora muchas de las vacunas
acaparadas por los ricos están venciendo
sin ser utilizadas 10 países entre ellos
Estados Unidos Reino Unido Japón y
Alemania tendrían a finales de 2022
miles de millones de dosis excedentes
con un gran riesgo de desperdicio
potencial y yo me pregunto después de
toda la que hemos pasado podemos
permitirnos como humanidad desperdiciar
vacunas
y pero es interesante no es decir que
está pasando
Es difícil de haberse aprendemos no es
decir el tema de esta pandemia es un
poco como el medio ambiente son dos
temas las dos únicos objetos políticos
que superan las fronteras no sé qué Y si
no vemos Que si nos ponemos no nos
ponemos de acuerdo son temas que no se
pueden resolver a nivel nacional como la
política económica que se puede otros
otros te donde estamos dando cuenta de
eso y las vacunas y las desigualdades
están poniendo en evidencia este tema no
vale dos dos temas que parecen
importantes las patentes y hable de eso
se habló en un momento incluso no habría
que suspender las patentes para que
podamos bueno se habló dura un mes y ha
desaparecido el debate público hay que
volver a poner en la mesa salgamos de
las patentes porque estamos generando un
problema mayor segundo a la
concentración de la industria
farmacéutica solo 4 o 5 industrias son
capaces de producir esta vacuna como
puede ser eso pues hay un problema en la
industria farmacéutica que es la mega
concentración de la industria en tres o
cuatro países no bueno puesto esto es la
pandemia es útil porque nos hace ver lo
que no va Lo que no está funcionando en
nuestras en nuestra organización
sociopolítica y económica no pero bueno
Parece que la voluntad de momento no
está ahí para que avancemos hacia un
mundo mejor el motivo de este
desperdicio si bien lo entiendo y bueno
es que en las vacunas tienen una vida
útil de 6 meses según los estudios que
se hicieron en su momento y ahora la m
se está pidiendo tiempo para que monitor
dicen si es tiempo de vida puede
alargarse porque si no ahora mismo ya
estarían caducando las vacunas de
principios de año no
pues ahora sí que me tomaste en curva no
sé la verdad es que no sé pero bueno es
un tema complejo es decir que por un
lado como dices tú los países ricos
tienen muchas dosis de vacunas e incluso
no vayamos muy lejos aquí en la Mejía
educamos aquí en la en el ayuntamiento
de París ayuntamiento del 15 este sale
una señora y dice nos quedan dosis por
favor avisen este porque no sé si se nos
están quedando las dosis ahorita en en
estos meses imagen de desperdiciar unas
dosis yo creo que no no la podemos
permitir no como sociedad totalmente es
No pues no es ético no es ético cuando
estás viendo tanta gente que se está
muriendo Porque si hay gente que se está
muriendo yo quisiera dar testimonio
acabo de entrevistar a una a un doctor
del Hospital Civil de Guadalajara en
México ese este hospital es
ellos acogen a los que ni siquiera
tienen seguro social son los pobres de
los pobres no y y la gente están
llegando muy jóvenes entre 30 y 40 años
personas que están siendo entubadas y
que 60% de estas personas están muriendo
fíjateros claro
le pregunté le pregunté porque una de
las discusiones es que si estás vacunado
te puedes contagiar es que si estás
vacunado Puedes ir a los servicios de
terapia intensiva Sí pero en este caso
le pregunté bueno de estas personas que
ustedes están atendiendo Cuántos están
vacunados y me dijo nadie nadie está
vacunado entonces
yo de primera fuente sé que todas las
personas o la gran mayoría de las
personas que están siendo hospitalizadas
en ya en decir con muchas dificultades
de respiración este 95% están no
vacunadas pregunta compleja un ejemplo
de todo esto de la copia de vacunas es
la llamada tercera dosis aprobada ya
como Reino Unido Israel o Francia no sé
si se trata de calmar a los electorados
de países ricos Cristian Sí me parece
que es hablar con su electorado no con
los expertos porque ahora con la
vacunación tenemos dos tipos de
contaminados Y eso tiene que seguir
tenemos los contaminados que son
vacunados y probablemente no van a ser
hospitalizados no van a hacer fuerzas
graves Y tenemos los contaminados que no
han sido vacunados y es así que correr
en mucho disco hiervos Entonces cuando
en Francia hablamos de la tercera dosis
Y todavía tenemos mucha gente en países
meso los países artistas o países que
están en contacto todo el tiempo cuando
cuando miramos como la Argelia Argelia
tiene 10% de vacunados y la
gente que viene de Argelia y va ahí Esto
del tiempo hace con que el virus late se
transmitir
Entonces nos podemos pensar como decía
Juan no podemos pensar dentro de las
fronteras porque el virus no va a estar
limitado por las fronteras en este
debate que confluye entre política y
ética y ciencia Yo me pregunto si no lo
hacemos por principios lo de solidaridad
y lo de vacunar a todo el mundo por qué
ni siquiera tenemos el reflejo de
hacerlo por egoísmo es decir pensar que
pueden surgir nuevas variantes que
retrasen aún más el final de la pandemia
sino vacunamos a todo el mundo es que ni
siquiera tenemos el reflejo egoísta de
pensarlo muy buena pregunta pero yo creo
que más en este sentido más que me falta
de de de de lucidez por parte de los
gobernantes es falta de capacidad es
decir realmente creo que si tú
preguntaras a los países más ricos te
dirían hay que hay que estructurar esta
respuesta no creo que sea egoísmo sino
que no estamos acostumbrados no existe
la multilateralidad a nivel sanitario de
salud No lo hemos construido y no hay
las estructuras para hacerlo entonces
como estamos actuando
eso toma tiempo de generar una
estructura que permite esa coordinación
a nivel mundial la otan es a nivel
occidental y militar tomó varios años en
montar una estructura que funcionara
pues lo mismo habría que hacer un poco
lo mismo a nivel de salud es básicamente
más que egoísmo yo creo falta de
capacidad y de Inercia y de cultura casi
de la cooperación y del multiliteralismo
político en este debate de la tercera
dosis
no la tercera dosis Yo pienso que se
bueno como en todas las vacunas llega un
momento en que tu inmunidad adquirida
pues va bajando Entonces por ejemplo en
el caso de personas mayores que tienen
más dificultad de hacer sus anticuerpos
en el caso de personas que tienen una un
transplante de riñones etcétera ellas
está especificado y que ya se está
haciendo se está haciendo yo tengo una
amiga que tiene un trasplante de riñón y
ella pero se le hizo primero una prueba
anticuerpos creo que lo lógico es
primero se hacer una prueba de
anticuerpos de sangre ver si tienes
anticuerpos y si es un nivel bajo
entonces una tercera dosis entonces Y si
ves los tiempos si ya mucha gente empezó
a vacunarse con segunda dosis en abril
Es lógico que ya en octubre noviembre
quizás necesitan una tercera dosis yo lo
veo más bien por el lado de necesidad
médica Pero también es verdad que es una
incoherencias y mucha gente no está
vacunada que aquí estamos ya vacunando
con la tercera dosis y Mientras tanto en
varios países como por ejemplo aquí en
Francia esta semana arranca el nuevo
curso escolar con también varias
incógnitas que se ha aprendido de la
transmisión en la docencia se ha
preparado bien está la llamada Ren 3
color aquí en Francia Cristian cómo lo
ve bueno hay cosas que sí que aprendemos
entonces hay más testeces de la gente
está la distanciación de eso se guardan
las mascarillas se guardan pero por
ejemplo el tema de la ventilación dentro
de sala de ala en Alemania hace un año
Las clases son abiertas las ventanas de
Las clases son abiertas a cada 20
minutos para que cambie el aire en
Francia todavía hay un protocolo de qué
hacer y en otros países igual y sabemos
de base más que el aerosol que el covid
se pasa por el aerosol entonces las
mascarillas quirúrgicas simples no se no
bastan tenemos también que hacer la
ventilación sobre todo porque ahí está
en el invierno que llega dentro de tres
meses
así las cosas siente La amenaza Delta
varios países que ya habían eliminado
medidas como llevar mascarillas han
tenido que retropedalear Esto va a ser
nuestro nuestra rutina hasta el final de
la crisis sanitaria es decir ahora vamos
a volver a las mascarillas
nuevas variantes Esto va a ser un
continuum un bucle continuo en el que
vamos a estar Espero que no Carlos
porque estamos hartos eso también yo
creo que sucede eso es también una un
factor una variante que está presente yo
creo que la gente ya está muy cansada
muy cansada de todo esto Me parece que
lo de la ventilación es muy importante y
que no se hace esa se insistió tanto en
la sana distancias insistió tanto en la
mascarilla pero creo que eso es lo de la
ventilación es algo muy importante y muy
sencillo es bastante sencillo de llevar
a cabo pero bueno esperemos que que ya
que cómo lo ves pues el segundo de los
límites yo creo antes decías tú a veces
se habla electorado bueno la clase
política en general habla electoral de
su público no y pero yo creo que el
límite del doctorado es justamente es lo
que hice y bueno no hay un momento en
que la gente ya va a estar estamos un
poco cansados y lo vamos a estar cada
vez más como estamos en una lógica de
stop and go No paramos volvemos volvemos
para atrás seguimos para adelante
volvemos atrás eso no se puede sostener
a nivel político y a nivel electoral a
largo plazo eso es seguro Entonces igual
por ahí igual por ahí tengo esperanza de
que se diga bueno Vamos a organizarnos a
nivel mundial para ver cómo le hacemos
para que todo el mundo pueda acceder la
vacuna que es la única la única vía de
solución a largo plazo y dejemos de cada
país ahora me hago esto ahora cierro los
bares no eso no es sostenible a largo
plazo para mí es una de las vías de
salida es que justamente la clase
política sería ya no funciona y a nivel
electoral eso ya no nos da rédito por lo
cual hay que cambiar la estrategia y
vamos a promover las patentes
lateralidad etcétera
no sé no sé si son muy optimistas en
cambiar la perspectiva de la clase
política respecto a la solidaridad
mundial con las vacunas eh yo lo veo un
poco complicado pero no no soy Cristian
sabemos que no hay otra salida el
problema es quién lo hace porque sabemos
que toda la población mundial Es que
vacunarla para acabar con esta crisis
pero no sé si es tan fácil ponerlo en
marcharíamos la Italia que estaba toda
toda cerrada y decíamos no eso no es
posible y después hemos cerrado en
Francia cuatro veces hay muchas cosas
que antes parecían imposible de hacer y
se puede hacer cuando vemos que en otros
sitios eso
ha funcionado que podemos hacer Igual
entonces creo que hay mucho que aprender
con las experiencias de otros hace un
año y medio que vemos cosas que están
bien en otros países de que están malas
Entonces tenemos que aprender más con
los que lo que hacen los vecinos fijarse
en las cosas buenas que hacen nosotros
para intentar copiarla lo mejor posible
que apareciera una nueva mutante que
fuera resistente a las vacunas ahí sí
eso sí sería lo peor madre mía no vamos
a pensar que no va a pasar vamos a
pensar que no va a pasar para acabar hoy
con un con una señal alguna señal de
optimismo Bueno pues muchísimas gracias
a los tres ha sido un placer compartir
con ustedes Este primer programa de la
cuarta temporada ya de en Primera Plana
y a todos ustedes les esperamos el
próximo viernes aquí en radio Francia
internacional y en francés 24 Muchísimas
gracias
[Música]